anfahren abheben und einfach
wolfgang labuhn über seiner
lieblingsbeschäftigung am tag der
offenen tür auf dem flugplatz neustadt
klebe in mecklenburg vorpommern macht
der geschäftsführer einer flugzeug
manufaktur den jungfernflug mit einer
aero lite 120 einem ultraleichtflugzeug
seine frau tilger fiebert wie immer mit
ausgestattet mit einem kleinen motor und
tank erreicht das flugzeug gemütliche 90
kilometer pro stunde und lässt sich bis
zu zwei stunden fliegen
das tolle ist dass du
eigenverantwortlich ganz den elementen
ausgeliefert ist und dass du einfach
aufgrund deiner erlernten kenntnisse die
maschine beherrscht und beherrschen muss
um halt wieder heile an am boden an zu
gelangen und das ist eine
herausforderung das macht spaß das ist
nervenkitzel und das ist einfach ein
tolles gefühl auf der flugshow ist die
green bird ein blickfang nicht nur wegen
ihrer auffälligen farbe
der flieger ist unkompliziert und der
pilot benötigt nur einen flugschein für
leichte luft sportgeräte um sie steuern
zu dürfen
der traum vom fliegen eine uhr sehnsucht
der menschen
mich fasziniert eigentlich immer dass so
eine schwere maschinen und auch diese
leicht machen dass sie so also
problemlos schweden ins flugzeug steigen
kann die komplett abschalten und so die
welt von oben dass eine andere
blickwinkel die man hat und so ein
freiheitsgefühl 1891 vor 125 jahren
beginnt die geschichte des fliegens der
ingenieur otto lilienthal gleitet als
erster mensch mit einem selbstgebauten
flugapparat nahe berlin 20 meter durch
die luft
viele weitere flüge folgen
in seiner heimatstadt anklam in
mecklenburg vorpommern widmet sich ein
museum dem deutschen flugpionier und
zeigt seine flugapparate in
rekonstruktion 18 unterschiedliche baute
otto lilienthal verwendete dafür weide
bambus leinwand und hat als vorbilder
dienten ihm störche deren flug her jahre
lang studierte
mit 43 jahren begann otto lilienthal mit
seinen ersten flugversuchen nur fünf
jahre später stürzte er ab und starb an
den schweren verletzungen
owlient hat das jahrhunderte alte
geheimnis des flügels gegner aus
heutiger sicht wenn man guckt was ist
denn eigentlich am flugzeug nach
lilienthal dann ist es eigentlich die
physik des flügels also wir beschreiben
auch ein airbus flügel mit den begriffen
die sich ihren teil mal vor 125 ml 430
jahr ausgedacht hat
zurück zu wolfgang labuhn nur rund 30
kilometer luftlinie von otto lilienthals
geburtsort entfernt fertig der
flugzeugbauer die aero lite 120 in
handarbeit das material leichtes
luftfahrt aluminium und polyester gewebe
bezieht seine firma vier werk aus den
usa
die zwölf unterschiedlichen designs
entwickelt sie selbst
das ist ein tolles gefühl sie machen
einen karton auf sie neben einzelteile
heraus sie müssen diese anteile
bearbeiten sie müssen sicher sein das
was sie tun auch korrekt ist und am ende
sitzen sie da drin fliegen damit fliegen
die welt von oben betrachten das
fasziniert auch tilda wurde
sie selbst hat zwar keinen flugschein
aber die magie des fliegens beschäftigt
sie schon lange
wir haben sehr hohen respekt gerade bei
otto lilienthal wie er als pionier sich
eine vision vorgestellt hat fliegen zu
lernen und wir empfinden der 14 stück
weit nach ja mit unserer art der der
fliegerei und ich glaube dass menschen
immer noch abenteuerlustig sind im
besten sinne des wortes ohne war eisig
zu sein
das unmittelbare flugerlebnis haben die
offene aero lite und lilienthals modelle
gemeinsam
doch längst ist das flugzeug mehr als
ein abenteuer es ist zu einem der
wichtigsten verkehrsmittel geworden